في كل مونديال وفي كل استحقاق رياضي تعود
النغمه القديمه مواجهه بين الرجال والنساء
حول اولويات الرياضه لكن الواقعه بالارقام
نساء عربيات يتابعنا المونديال اكثر من اي
وقت مضى ومع ذلك ان الرجال في مصر ما اغرب
سؤال سالته زوجتكم بخصوص كاس العالم متابع
[موسيقى]
ممكن تسهل يعني
مثلا في الماتش بتاع
اليابان والكوستاريكا
سالتني تفتكر ال- ال- الفريق العوجر ده
اللي مش عارف يوصل للجون ده ممكن يكسب قلت
لها والله ربنا كبير
ههه هو اغرب سؤال سالتني اياه كم هدف
محتاج حتى نتاهل للادوار النهائيه في كاس
العالم بتقول لي همم
ضيعوا اترككم والحاجات دي في كاس العالم
والوقت كده اهوت قلت له احنا كل اربع سنين
بنشوفه مره وحاجه بنتمتع بها بعد الماتش
ما خلص مصر وبلجيكا بتسالني احنا هنقابل
مين في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كاس العالم مع ازواجهم
[موسيقى]
اثناء شغلي بالبيت
نحطه على التلفزيون وعلى الصوت العالي وان
شاء الله التوفيق للمنتخبات العربيه كون
اشتغل بالبيت واجي احضر ولما يصير هدف من
يصير نشجع يعني اجواء حلوه اجواء رائعه
وحلوه اول شيء نحن من السعوديه
حماسيه وتشجيع ومع السعوديه بكل المباريات
بس انا بدي اياها علينا
[موسيقى]
حسب المباراه اوقات بالكوفي شوب اوقات
بالبيت بس اكيد هي بتعمل اجواء حماسيه
للكل الموجودين على التلفزيون
جميله جدا
[موسيقى]
الحديث عن النساء في المونديال
نذهب الى الدوحه
الجميله ريان الظاهر ريان يسعد صباحك طبعا
ريان مراسله صباح العربيه في السودان ومن
المعلقين الرياضيين والمهتمين جدا بشان
الكرهوي صح يا ريان
يسعد صباحك سهام تحياتي شكرا يعني
الافتتاح هكذا ملف مهم جدا هو تشجيع
النساء لكره القدم لكن بدايه تندعيني
اعترض على اجابه نادين خماش على السؤال
التفاعلي بانها تنضم لمجموعه النساء التي
يشجعنا كره القدم لاجل نيمار بالطبع انتم
لم تروا ديبالا اسينسيو رونالدو
ههه يسعد صباحكم اولا طبعا يعني الجدل
الكبير يثار هذه الايام بسبب اهتمام
النساء بالمونديال انا بالامس كنت همم
يعني فضيت همم باني اكون من داخل همم
استاد الجنوب ل اشاهد واتابع من داخل
الملعب مباراه
الكاميرون وصربيا جدا كانت مباراه رائعه
وقويه طبعا انتهت المباراه بالتعادل وكنت
مشجعه همم يعني الكاميرون همم تلك الهويه
الافريقيه الساحره اكيد نحن مفتورين بها
ولا ننتمي اليها لكن همم
[موسيقى]
المراه كانت حاضره من داخل الملعب كان لها
صوت يعلو داخل الملعب بالطبع تشجيع النساء
سيصبح بالضروره امر عادي وذلك لا ينفي
بانه اصبح موضه يعني
في بعض النساء
نور ايضا لافته من تشجيع النساء في
مونديال قطر حتى الان
همم طيب بدايه همم دعيني اشيد بالتنظيم
الرائعه والساحر لمونديال قطر 20 22 همم
والفعاليات المصاحبه يعني قبل الدخول ل
همم المباراه هنا للتعدد من الفعاليات
تلاقي شعوب والثقافات الكبيره وايه داخل
الملعب الامر مختلف نادين انا هذه المره
الاولى التي همم متابع فيها مباراه من
داخل الملعب يعني همم
فالامر مختلف تماما عن تشجيع خارج الملعب
وعن بعد تماما همم اقترامك من جوه الملعب
همم وجودك وانت محاطه بمجموعه من المشجعين
بتحس انه بيجمعكم حب كره القدم كره القدم
ليست مجرد لعبه همم يعني ما يشهده
المونديال الان من الاهتمام العالمي
الكبير وما تشهده كره القدم عموما من
المنشات الرياضيات من اهتمام عالمي كبير
ضروري يؤكد انها ليست مجرد همم بحر وانها
عشق يعني
ازلي وابدي
يعني ريان اعطتنا الجانب المشرق لدعم
السيدات والنساء ماذا عن السيدات والنساء
السودانيات هل لهن متحمسات مهتمات بكره
القدم بشكل عام
في المراه السودانيه حكون صادقه معك همم
يعني ما مهتم جدا بمساله كره القدم ده همم
هم همم يعني اهتماما ممكن يكون ضعيف في
بعض المشجعات القليلات وقبل ايام صباحا
العربيه
متعصبه جدا همم حاضره همم
بيسالوا اسئله قد تبدو غريبه يعني همم
المحطه السابقه بالاردن وهمم في مصر كانت
انه في اسئله بيت الشعري انه المراه بعيده
كل البعد من الموضوع همم ما بيعرفوا مثلا
همم الفرق بين المنتخب والفريق
ههه
ففي اسئله نحن بنستهجنا على المتابعه
الجيد لكره القدم قد يشعر انها
ليست يعني ذكيه او غبيه يعني اسئله غبيه
وايضا فقط ريان يعني لكي نخطب معك نشير
يعني اشرنا الى جمال اللاعبين ولا نانسي
ايضا جمال المشجعات اللواتي احضرنا
بتعليقات المعلقين من على مدرجات
المباريات
ويصبحنا ترد والصوره عامه شكرا لك الزميله
شكرا
نعم
سؤال اخير انت بتشجعي على اي منتخب وكمان
سهام
المنتخب عشان اعرف انكم متابعين ولا لا
اولا لازم تتابعيني على السوشيال ميديا
عشان تعرفي الاسئله ما نسالها
المنتخبات العربيه طبعا قلبا وقالبا ولكن
البرازيل اولا
البرازيل مبروك علينا الفوز امس
وتاهل الدور النهائي
طب شكرا الى اللقاء شكرا